في المقابل قالت هيئه الاركان العامه
للجيش الاوكراني ان قواتها تصدت لمئه
وخمسين هجوما روسيا على خمسه محاور شرقيه
اوكرانيا خلال الاربع والعشرين ساعه
الماضيه
واكدت الهيئه ان القوات الروسيه لا تتوقف
عن محاوله تطويق مدينه بخموت وفرض حصار
عليها لكن القوات الاوكرانيه تكبدها خسائر
بشريه كبيره حسب تعبيرها
واضافت الهيئه في بيان ان القوات الروسيه
تواصل محاوله تركيزه هجماتها في اتجاهات
باخموت ولمان
يختار في مقاطعه دونياسك وكوبياسك في
مقاطعه
بينما تحاول تعزيز مواقعها في منطقه
ينضم الينا مراسلنا امين برغامي كما ينضم
الينا من غرب بخموت مراسلنا حسان مسعود
حسان اخر تطورات المعارك في مخموت
[موسيقى]
نعم اخر التطورات كانت زياره ايضا جديده
لمسؤول عسكري كبير هو قائد العمليات
الخاصه في الجيش الاوكراني الى هنا الى
منطقه باخموت للاطلاع على الاوضاع في
الجبهه وهذه الجبهه التي اكد انها تعيش
اوضاعا شديده الصعوبه وشديده الخطوره لكن
في تصريحه خلال زيارته اكد على ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تعمل بشكل حثيث على تقليل عدد
القوات المعاديه وفق تعبيره وهو ما يعني
ايقاع المزيد من الخسائر في القوات
الروسيه التي تهاجم هذه المنطقه هذه
المنطقه التي ننظر اليها الان هي اخر
التلال التي تشرف على مواقع تمركز القوات
الروسيه في المنطقه الجنوبيه لمنطقه
باخموت المحاذيه
المنطقه الغربيه حيث نتواجد الان او حيث
نوجد الان هذه المنطقه هذه التلال خلفها
تتواجد القوات الروسيه وهي تقصف منطقه
باخموت وهذا الطريق الذي سنشاهده الان هو
من بين الطرقات التي لا ينصح بالتوجه من
خلالها باتجاه مدينه باخمت نظرا لتعرضه
هناك للقصف الشديد هذه المنطقه التي نوجد
فيها الان هي اخر المناطق التي يمكن
الدخول منها باتجاه منطقه باخمت
ونحن قبل قليل كنا قد زرنا منطقه شاسفيار
هذه البلده المدينه التي تقع
على بعد كيلو مترات قليله من منطقه
كروموفي هذه المنطقه التي قالت القوات
الروسيه انها دخلتها وسيطرت عليها وتفصل
بينها وبين منطقه باخموت وهناك القصف شديد
للغايه من القوات الروسيه من جهه وكذلك من
قبل القوات الاوكرانيه التي بدورها ايضا
تقصف القوات الروسيه التي تحاول التقدم
باتجاه مزيد من الاحياء باتجاه وسط مدينه
باخمت ومن منطقه تقوم بالقصف الشديد دون
توقف نحن اطلعنا على احوال ايضا السكان
هناك عندما زرنا المنطقه قبل قليل وقالوا
لنا انهم باتوا يسمعون القصف من ثلاث
اتجاهات بعدما كانت بعدما كانوا يسمعونها
من اتجاه او اتجاهين فقط وهذا يعني ايضا
ان شده القذف وان الاتجاهات التي تقصف
منها القوات الروسيه تزداد في محاوله من
هذا التطبيق لكن القوات الاوكرانيه تؤكد
ان باخمه ليست
محاصره بشكل ليست مطوقه بشكل كامل وربما
بما اننا نوجد في هذا المكان هذا يعني ان
هناك الجهه الغربيه ما زالت لدى القوات
الاوكرانيه ونحن نلاحظ بين الحين الاخر
تدخل الاليات والمدرعات الاوكرانيه باتجاه
منطقه باخمت ويخرج عدد من السكان ايضا من
هذه المنطقه
باتجاه المناطق الاوكرانيه في محاوله
لاجلاء ما تبقى من السكان الذين يوجدون
داخل مدينه باخت الذين يقدر عددهم انهم
بقوا 4000
نسمه فقط حتى هذه اللحظه في ظل الاوضاع
الصعبه التي تعيشها المدينه ارجو ان تبقى
معنا